i have the brand new razer blade advance  with the 12th generation intel processor  and today we're gonna compare it to the  16-inch macbook pro now i'm running  speedometer 2.0 that is the highest  score of any windows laptop or windows  desktop i have seen i'm gonna unplug it  and test it again it did go down but  it's still above what amd's best  processors get in their laptops when  they're plugged in razer when it's  plugged in is about 55 more powerful in  terms of graphics performance and then  on battery power that drops a lot it's a  much nicer system than before if you're  gaming of course this is the way to go  but if you're somebody doing video  editing photo editing different  productivity and if you're somebody who  cares about performance on battery and  battery life we do have a pretty big  difference the display is a lot nicer  for people who are doing that kind of  work